Move, honk, honk.
Pardon me.
Out of the way,
clavicle.
Okay, five-nine, I can't even,
like, deal with you right now.
Oh, do you guys all
have drinks already?
Maybe you should, then, get the
hell away from the bar, great.
Is anyone even working
at this bar?
Yes, hi.
What can I get you?
Um, I don't know,
what are the drinks?
The West Nile Coolatta
is very popular,
but I would recommend
the sex trafficking
on the beach or
the tsunami slide.
Well, I guess that I will
have two tsunami slides,
even though that name, I think,
is a little bit ridiculous.
Well, 6% of the proceeds
go to the tsunami.
What tsunami?
Whichever one
happens next.
Forward thinking,
I guess, then.
Or corruption.
Can I interest anyone
in a dose of reality?
Some mac and cheese ball
fried and truffoiled.
Oh, yeah.
I am saying
yes to that.
Just now a child in South
America died of starvation.
Would you
like another?
You know what?
I would.
Yeah.
They're very good.
They're really good.
Just now a child
in South Amer--
Hold on, do you just have
one fact that you repeat?